Rob McElhenney:
Mythic Quest, is the greatest
show
in the history of television.
Rob McElhenney:
All the writers, tons of the
directors,
Rob McElhenney:
a bunch of actors.
Roomfulls of Emmys.
Seems like everybody's got an
Emmy, except me.
(Off camera laughter)
♪♪
Rob McElhenney:
We've been really fortunate to
be able to come back for a season two.
And the entire team has just
been incredible.
We started shooting
the season and then got
shutdown because of the pandemic.
Megan Ganz:
And coming back in production,
really required a lot of
patience, a lot of cooperation.
♪♪
Hey, Snoop Doggy Dogg.
What's poppin', Bert?
It's Brad. But that's fine.
Fo sho.
Ashly Burch:
Even though this is a games
company.
I thinks what's really cool
about it is that it's much more
universal.
Ashly Burch:
You're working in a office with
other people.
So there is the same sorts of
problems.
Rob McElhenney:
People navigating work-life,
navigating love-life,
navigating life in general.
I'm a great boss. Tell them
Dana.
-No.
Sister-girl done flipped the
script.
David.
-David.
I'm Sorry.
I think that it's hot, it is
about a found family.
Charlotte Nicdao:
It's fun to watch, because it's
really easy to relate to that.
David:
What is that? What's happening?
-I can fix it. I-I just need to...Oh no.
She just crashed all the
servers.
♪♪
Aaaay.
In season two, we got more
jokes.
Very groovy.
Imani Hakim:
We got badass women.
I think you're the most talented
programmer of our generation.
We get to expose like these
deeper character traits within
the cast.
What are you doing?
-I'm hiding in my office, until
he leaves.
It's a power-play.
Is it?
-Yes, it is, Jo!
There's bitterness, envy,
jealous rage.
You're a toilet!
Aah!
-Aaah!
But we're family and we have a
better season because of it.
There's this tremendous,
powerful, cinematic explosion.
There's much to be discovered
and i'm so proud to be part of
it.
Even though I was included as a
zoom-head.
How do I look?
(All)
Actually not bad.
Will somebody roll his ass out
of here?
Rob McElhenney:
I feel so grateful to create
something authentic
to people's experience.
And I love coming to work for
that very reason.
It's just the people.
Oooh!
♪♪